voici ce qui attire des gens des quatre
coins du globe dans la région de masaï
mara au kenya la nature dans toute sa
splendeur
[Musique]
ici le temps semble arrêté
mais un organisme caritatif canadien
s'est senti interpellé par une autre
force un besoin urgent d'aider des
communautés dans cette région rurale
dans ces vidéos promotionnelles 8
cheriti autrefois enfants entraide dit
vouloir donner au village les moyens de
se sortir de la pauvreté notamment en
construisant des puits d'eau potable et
en bâtissant des écoles qui font
cruellement défaut
[Musique]
au coeur des activités bénéfices se
trouvent les fondateurs d'enfants
entraide les charismatiques frères marc
et take your browser
elle ouvre un changement
oui décès la générosité le mouvement de
retrait partie levé vous et faites du
bruit
les événements oui des sont organisées
partout en amérique du nord
des vedettes populaires galvanise la
foule pour inciter les jeunes à renée
des d'autres
[Applaudissements]
comme daniel jamme accueille des fonds
pour une clinique en aide kennedy
qui a amassé de l'argent avec sa classe
pour bâtir une école en sierra leone en
afrique ce qu'ils ont fait c'est adopter
un village
dans le modèle adopté un village les
dons sont destinés à des projets en
particulier comme bâtir des écoles
ce message a touché watson jordan ex
enseignant en caroline du nord
les événements oui sont tellement
passionnant et exaltant
j'ai participé à trois de ces événements
la première ils nous ont dit qu'on
pouvait construire une école au kenya
nike mais ça m'a frappé
imaginez l'impact sur des enfants qui
n'ont pas d'école
watson giardina donc amasser des fonds
pour bâtir une école en souvenir de son
fils william
était en balance j'ai reçu un courriel
dans lequel on disait que mon village
serait hier 4 j'étais ravi
bonjour je m'appelle everything une
foule de jeunes ont aussi amasser des
fonds pour d'autres jeunes et publier
des vidéos sur youtube com et vous
hitchcock neuf ans au manitoba
chaque fois que fait un don j'avais
écrit votre nom se rendre et qu
l'organisme leur disait que l'ours
qu'ils amassaient assez d'argent unis
cole serait construite au kenya ou
arrangerez avant ses dix mille de l'or
je vais envoyer tout l'argent à enfants
entrailles de culture g
jumbo à l'eau à tous mes amis de l'école
secondaire davidson qui ont mené à vous
remercier et ceux qui recueillait assez
d'argent pour faire construire une école
pouvait même se voir remercier de leur
générosité dans une vidéo on vous dit un
gros à saintes et saint amand le message
a résonné partout en amérique du nord
l'échec arrivait de toronto de la
floride de la colombie britannique signé
par des écoles des églises et des
groupes communautaires partout des
bénévoles à pied d'oeuvre pour changer
le monde
c'est un projet vraiment spécial dans
tous les élèves leurs familles les
enseignants avaient entendu parler ça me
tenait à coeur
roczen de silva répondu à l'appel
c'est le 30e jour elle fait 1,49 cm de
long et j'ai amassé 308 $ est
étudiant à l'école secondaire iroquois
rue du pré toronto il s'est laissé
pousser la barbe pour une collecte de
fonds organisée par sa classe pour la
construction d'une école au kenya
les élèves et la communauté avait le
sentiment d'avoir une école jumelles ou
kenya m dingue
dingue est la bonne
quelques années plus tard russian s'est
rendu sur place
j'ai rencontré l'enseignant il m'a fait
visiter l'ancienne école et il m'a
montré la nouvelle école qui avait été
construite avec nos dents
j'étais vraiment fier de voir ce qui
avait donné nos quatre années de
collecte de fonds
c'était génial
[Musique]
mais en 2020 un scandale politique
éclabousse le cabinet de justin trudeau
et terni la réputation de l'organisme
juste être dos va devoir s'expliquer sur
l'octroi de contrats sans appel d'offres
à l'organisme unis mais le premier
ministre persiste et signe unis n'a reçu
aucun traitement préférentiel de
traitement de faveur de la part du
gouvernement pour l'attribution d'un
contrat de 500 millions de dollars pour
le bénévolat étudiants ce qui a soulevé
des préoccupations parmi certains
donateurs parmi eux les lepic
aujourd'hui je vais parler au nom de ce
petit bonhomme
ways l'école louise can un comité
parlementaire a entendu le témoignage de
rides cohen en colère wall street n'aime
son nom son visage sa courte vie de
quatre ans et son héritage ont été
utilisés pour faire de l'argent pour
enfants très dur
dans cette vidéo kenya on voit rick owen
à l'école qu'il a entièrement financé à
la mémoire de son petit garçon mort dans
un accident
en vous donnant cette école je vous
donne mon fils
cowan dit avoir amassé plus de 160 mille
dollars avec d'autres donateurs
encouragé par
durant une activité de financement
télévisée il a dit à tous nos donateurs
qu'à chaque tranche de 10 mille ou douze
mille dollars une école à l'aide
construit 10 pts monsieur cohen dit
avoir appris plus tard que la plaque de
son fils avait été enlevée et remplacée
par celle d'un autre donateur qui avait
financé la même école fils droite mon
fils a été victime d'une fraude
les frères qui regorge en pleine gestion
de crise se présente avec leurs avocats
devant un comité parlementaire
a raison d'être fâché aucune parole ne
pourra effacer la peine que cette erreur
occasionné
les frères qui au burger affirme que le
fiasco de la plaque est une erreur ils
font rapidement porter le blâme à
d'autres
théoriquement ce serait un membre de
l'équipe du cognac nous allons
investiguer nous voulons comprendre ça
n'aurait pas dû se produire
mais les députés ne sont pas convaincus
votre description n'est pas tout à fait
juste oiseaux malades mais voici où je
suis d'accord avec vous
les frères qui augurent riposte ils sont
fiers du bilan des écoles construites et
remercie les jeunes qui les ont aidés
de ceux qu'on nous sommes déçus des
députés de tous les partis parce que ce
qui a été accompli par les éducateurs et
les élèves dans cette mais l'école est
remarquable et méritent d'être préservés
au cours des 25 dernières années nous
avons contribué à construire en 1500
écoles dans le monde ce que permis
d'instruire deux cent mille enfants
mais les députés veulent savoir où se
trouvent ses 1500 écoles la réponse
vient quatre semaines plus tard dans le
haut de la liste figure le kenya oui
charity affirme avoir construit
360 écoles primaires
l'équipe du sib ici a entrepris de
mettre ce chiffre à l'épreuve
est ce que d'autres donateurs comme
monsieur cohen ont financé la même école
oui charity n'a pas voulu révéler les
noms des donateurs invoquant la
protection des renseignements personnels
l'équipe a donc parcouru internet pour
trouver quiconque avait publiquement
annoncé avoir entièrement financer une
école primaire où kenya
dans les médias sociaux sur d'anciens
sites web des données sur trente
villages witcher étaient présents sont
compilés
il est apparu évident que les donateurs
croyait avoir entièrement financé plus
de 900 écoles primaires ou kenya ce qui
bien au-delà des 360 école que
l'organisme déclare avoir construit sans
tenir compte des dons qui n'ont pas été
rendus publics
oui charity envoyé cette photo du nicole
un donateur qu'il l'avait entièrement
financé étrangement c'est la même photo
qui a été envoyé à un autre donateur à
qui on a dit la même chose toutes ces
photos des mêmes écoles prise sous
différents angles ont elles aussi été
envoyé à de nombreux donateurs il n'y a
pas que les jeunes et des parents de yi
qui faisait des dons l'organisme pouvait
aussi compter sur des entreprises
partenaires comme la rbc dont les
campagnes ont financé des écoles et
d'autres projets au kenya
des organismes sans but lucratif comme
unstoppable disent aussi avoir amassé
des fonds pour faire construire cent
cinquante huit écoles primaires au kenya
la fondation du footballeur canadien
michael pinball clemons auraient financé
la construction de cent huit écoles
primaires au kenya wemhoff et chiffres
le groupe cheng chi rose a recueilli des
fonds pour faire construire des dizaines
d'écoles au kenya son fondateur telle
conway a été ambassadeur de witcher et
hydrique rapidement
pour tourner cette vidéo de
remerciements
mais l'équipe de siby ci a fait une
autre découverte
dans des vidéos sur youtube tirs cadrés
remercie différents donateurs
devant la nicole 20 kg
pour de nombreux donateurs ce lien
tangible avec les écoles qu'ils avaient
financé et ce qui comptait le plus
roxane de silva se souvient du jour où
il a atteint son objectif avec ses
camarades de classe
je suis allé remettre l'argent en main
propre bureau de toronto no on voulait
que ce soit un partenariat à long terme
et non un don unique j'ai été très clair
et les fondateurs d'enfants entraide
melon garantie
watson jarden a ressenti la même chose
quand il a reçu la photo de l'école
qu'il croyait avoir financé
j'espère rencontrer un ou deux enfants à
qui je pourrais lire des livres que je
n'ai pas pu lire à williams
ce serait significatif pour moi
je suis déterminé à aller au village
s'il y allait que trouverait-il on lui
envoie une photo de l'école numéro 4
construite haïr carte à la mémoire de
son fils tout comme rick owen
pourrait-il découvrir ou kenya que son
école a aussi été financé par d'autres
est ce qu'il existe vraiment l'équipe de
sibiti a décidé de se rendre au kenya
pour trouver les écoles de watson jarden
de russian de silva et d'autres
oui charity a longtemps été active dans
les régions rurales du kenya l'organisme
canadien didier avoir construit 360
écoles primaires avec l'argent des
donateurs
pourtant les chiffres compilés indique
que les dons auraient pu permettre de
bâtir plus de 900 écoles devant cette
différence inexplicable l'équipe de siby
ci s'est rendu au kenya pour voir ce
qu'il en est
les écoles de witt cheriti sont situés
dans la région de masaï mara au sud
ouest du kenya
il n'y a pas ici de plus grand allié de
witt cheriti que le gouverneur du comté
de narok l'honorable samuel tu n'as
bonjour
le journaliste de fêter state mchale il
a rencontré
je suis un grand défenseur de huy
charity oui parce que j'ai vu
l'incidence des interventions et la
transformation qu'ont connu nos villages
comme gouvernement le faut nous devons
toujours chercher du financement
extérieur public pour combler le manque
de budget il a été on ne peut plus clair
sur la qualité du travail de witt
cheriti on ne peut pas en douter
walgreen pourquoi je critiquerai le
travail de richard iti alors que ça
donne de l'emploi et que des écoles
secondaires ont été construites vous
voudriez que je dise qu'ils ne font pas
un bon travail
quand on lui a demandé si c'était
possible que plus de fonds étaient été
amassés pour son compte et que ce qui a
réellement été dépensés le gouverneur
n'a pas voulu se prononcer je n'ai pas
de commentaire à faire
l'équipe a montré aux gouverneurs les
photos de ces mêmes bâtiments envoyé à
certains donateurs à qui l'on disait
qu'il les avait entièrement financé je
n'ai pas de commentaire à faire
bon séjour au kenya merci c'est ainsi
que le gouverneur a mis fin à l'entrevue
déclinant de répondre à d'autres
questions
[Musique]
avant d'arriver aux kenyans l'équipe
avait organisé une visite avec le
directeur de l'école de moto ni mais sur
place un inconnu vient parler au
directeur john and giroux qui a couvert
witcher ici au kenya et qui accompagne
nos collègues leur dit que le directeur
a reçu des pressions
il a dit avoir reçu des appels
votre présence n'est pas bienvenu
le soir même l'équipe apprend que leur
patron à toronto ont reçu un courriel de
l'avocat de witt cheriti quelques heures
après la rencontre avec le gouverneur du
naye on y cite des extraits de
l'entrevue
l'avocat de witt cheriti affirme qu il
apparaît clairement que si bissy à
présenter de l'information erronée comme
étant des faits
siby 6 à 10 familles oui charity
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
ce n'était qu'une partie de la campagne
entreprise par l'organisme pour mettre
fin à l' enquête
[Musique]
on approche dire 4 on le voit à
l'horizon
personne n'est à l'école en ce samedi où
les quais bas rive haïr cas dans
l'espoir d'y trouver l'école numéro 4
celle sur la photo car si watson jarden
l'équipe a compilé des données sur
l'historique de chacune des écoles ici
de l'information peut être inconnu des
donateurs
ce qu'on adore
l'école numéro 4 financé par watson
jordan à la mémoire de son fils mais
aussi par d'autres
les données indiquent que l'école numéro
4 a entièrement été financés au moins
quatre fois et ce n'est pas la seule
une photo d'une autre école apparaît à
mettre prise en ligne
l'école numéro ans a été financée par
blutch to humanity la fondation en stop
beau matin me wrong et la famille
goergen
les recherches montrent que oui charity
a dit aux donateurs qu'ils avaient
entièrement financé 70 écoles primaires
le total sur place 28
la visite est encore écourté john dit
qu'il faut partir
vous devez partir maintenant parce qu'il
ya eu des appels ça ne va pas du tout
les appels en question proviennent du
bureau du gouverneur
le gouverneur tout va et vient d'appeler
john pense que le gouverneur envoient
des messages pour que les journalistes
cessent les visites dans son comté
après herkat l'équipe se rend à rome
jenna dans le but de voir l'école que le
jeune manitobain evreux scob 9 ans a
fondé de chez lui
l'équipe y trouve l'école financée par
bruce canada rbc est aussi evry skog
les écoles sont minimalistes meublé de
bureau de ban et d'un tableau
une vue aérienne mais ce village en
perspective d'après les données
compilées on aurait dit aux donateurs
qu'ils ont entièrement financé 55 écoles
sur place il n'y a que douze écoles et
une bibliothèque
l'équipe s'arrête ensuite dans un
complexe de huy charity dans le comté de
norak
à la demande de l'organisme l'équipe
visite les installations avec carole
mort à une dirigeante de l'organisation
sur place
on accueille en moyenne 100 patients par
jour avec son hôpital qui abrite une
maternité une salle d'opération une
clinique au vide ce complexe est le
fleuron de witt cheriti ou kenya
on y trouve également l'école secondaire
qui accueille 280 élèves tous a financé
par de généreux donateurs
reconnu par des plaques
en entrevue caro mora soutient qu'il est
mal avisé de compter les écoles
ce n'est pas la bonne approche ça
démontre que vous ne comprenez pas notre
modèle
vous comptez les bâtiments à partir de
feuilles de données par it's not about
ce ne sont pas les infrastructures qui
compte mais leur incidence lévy que ça
touche tous les jours des
carreaux mora explique oui charity
finance aussi l'accès à l'eau potable et
aux soins de santé en plus de
l'éducation qui comprend la construction
d'écoles de bibliothèques de cuisine et
de logements pour le personnel
enseignant
mais les recherches de nos collègues
tiennent déjà compte de cette réalité on
met tout en oeuvre pour être le plus
transparent possible elles insistent les
donateurs savent que leur argent sert à
plusieurs projets les photos qu'on leur
envoie ne signifie pas qu'ils ont
entièrement financer l'école en question
ou el abdallah francs aux donateurs
financent au village on lui envoie
évidemment une photo du village to do la
halde est nommé il n'est pas le seul à
le financer les causes des villages ne
contient pas seulement une classe vide
il ya aussi des élèves dans la classe
qui ont accès à des repas et à des
dépistages le personnel enseignant
reçoit des formations au death tout cela
est mis en place avec l'infrastructure
l'infrastruture
après s'être faits reprochés de compter
les écoles l'équipe découvre que c'est
précisément ce que oui charity a fait
durant le printemps et l'été qui ont
suivi le début de l' enquête le nombre
avancé devant les membres du parlement
360 a considérablement changé
est le bon nombre et 852 we had not on
n'avait pas inclus les rénovations les
écoles secondaires ni les écoles
secondaires
régionales ça ne tenait pas compte non
plus des nouvelles constructions
construction et déconstruction retardé
en raison de la coved microsoft profite
pas le manager d'aston gibb le parlement
nous avait demandé combien
d'infrastructures nous détenions
practice d'athlète mais on n'avait pas
pris tout ça en compte avant d'avancer
un chiffre et for giving back ce n'est
pas close on a donc refait nos calculs
pour arriver au chiffre final
de 852
un examen plus attentif du nouveau
chiffre avancé révèle qui comprend les
écoles secondaires les cuisines et même
lille latrines ce qui vient gonfler le
total mais le décompte de l'organisme
confirme le nombre d'écoles primaire
construite au kenya 360
wii charity réitère tout de même que
tous les dons versés pour le kenya ont
été dépensés au pays et les villages qui
en ont bénéficié manifeste une loyauté
inconditionnel
ap hm vignette on a fièrement hisser le
drapeau de witt cheriti pour accueillir
les journalistes canadienne
ils ont creusé des puits tout ce qui a
été construit ici est l'oeuvre de huy
charity
ici l'équipe cherche l'école financée
par russian de silva
savait-il que l'école qu'il considérait
être la sienne avec ses camarades de
classe avaient été financés par d'autres
ap hm vignette l'équipe a relevé 20
écoles d'après les données compilées
witcher iti avait reçu des dons pour en
financer entièrement 48
nos collègues constatent l'écart entre
leurs chiffres et ceux avancés par
l'organisme dans tous les villages un
après l'autre
[Musique]
est ce que tous les donateurs ce avec
leur argent serait mis en commun avec
les dents d'autres personnes pour
financer différents projets
non non on nous avait dit que c'était un
erreur financer le projet il fonde sur
la photo qu'il a prise lors de sa visite
à peine vignette roczen de silva n'avait
pas remarqué qu'un indice sur le
bâtiment souligné la générosité de
quelqu'un d'autre
il s'agit des lettres m pcf associé à la
fondation michael pinball clemons qui
avait aussi entièrement financé cette
même école
je ne savais pas
si c'est vrai c'est très décevant
petit
plus tard le soir même l'équipe reçoit
un appel d'un ancien employé de witcher
éthique qui veut garder l'anonymat par
peur de poursuites judiciaires
cette source affirme que c'était
pratique courante de sueur financer des
projets au kenya hypo seulement des
écoles
de la morgue elle permettait de faire de
l'argent à la question qui est derrière
ce stratagème la source n'a pas hésité
cela a duré des années selon m
[Musique]
moins d'une heure après cet appel
l'équipe a reçu un texto de toronto
celui-ci a reçu une lettre du ministère
de l'intérieur du kenya elle contient
des allégations non fondées selon
lesquelles l'équipe journalistique a
commis des actes criminels au kenya dont
une intrusion sur la propriété du
gouvernement pour une raison inconnue
oui charity se trouvait en copie de la
lettre
inquiète pour leur sécurité
6 bis et ordonne aux journalistes de se
rendre immédiatement à l'aéroport
c'est la fin de la mission kenya
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien ma maison de star à
l'africaine je m'appelle craig
kielburger j'ai fondé enfants en 13 il y
a une dizaine d'années craig kielburger
a tourné cette vidéo pour mtv en
amérique du nord à 5,5 m comment vas-tu
guerriers massaï est mon ami il vit ici
c'est la villa où le gel et donateurs
fortunés de witt charité ou kenya le
volet à but lucratif de l'organisme
laissez-moi vous montrer mon chez moi
mais ce faisant les frais requis au
burger pratiquer la charité bien
ordonnée wachma bars salles de bains
relaxer se détendre et avoir un point de
vue sur la nature du masaï mara
et leur événement était digne des plus
grands concerts rock
indie on peut devenir qui on veut si on
s'y met
mais que se passe-t-il en coulisses
alors que les dons affluaient
l'équipe de siby ci a parlé à des
dizaines de personnes qui ont eu des
liens avec l'organisme
un employé a accepté de discuter par
watt sac
la source a demandé d'être
confidentielles parce qu'elle crée les
poursuites et aussi le pouvoir des
frères qui au bugue
la source a affirmé que le
surfinancement des écoles était une
stratégie qui venait des hauts
dirigeants les frères étaient au courant
de tout ça est accepté de prendre le
risque lié à ce mode de financement tout
ce qui importait c'était l'objectif
global
si l'opération était ambitieuse et
foncièrement bonne les moyens semblait
avoir peu d'importance quand notre
collègue lui a demandé en quoi cela
était foncièrement bon la source a
répondu que l'objectif était plus
important que la façon de l'atteindre
d'autres sources s'inquiète que oui
charity est accepté des dons pour des
projets déjà financés
vous savez que les frères k o burger ont
été prévenus vous jouez avec le feu je
ne sais pas comment ils ont pu penser
pouvoir s'en tirer si longtemps il était
vraiment bon pour offrir une expérience
que les gens n'allaient pas remettre en
question
[Musique]
les ennuis de huy charity ont eu des
échos jusqu'au aux états unis où
l'organisme a recueilli près de 200
millions de dollars en 10 ans
à chicago le groupe cerruti watch évalue
les organismes pour guider les donateurs
il a suspendu son évaluation de witt
cheriti en 2020 en invoquant des
problèmes de gouvernance
sa directrice générale
maurice tard elle compte 15 ans
d'expérience dans le secteur de la
philanthropie
nos collègues lui présente les photos
identique witcher été envoyé à divers
donateurs
ça semble être la même mais connaissent
pas
c'est un point vraiment les nuages et
tout le reste c'est pareil je vois
c'est vraiment problématique parce que
ça semble pas être une erreur et a
plutôt une stratégie de financement qui
vise à inciter les donateurs à donner
plus d'argent
alors qu'on leur promet que les fonds
serviront à une fin bien précise
de violence et les donateurs et le grand
public doivent exiger qu'une enquête
soit menée
ce n'est visiblement pas le souhaitent
tous un groupe de donateurs dont bon
nombre disent avoir visité les projets
de woods charité ou kenya ont lancé une
virulente campagne pour faire cesser
l'anc est journalistique nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec la thèse selon
laquelle nous les donateurs avons été
lésés ils ont envoyé des courriels aux
rédacteurs en chef de 6 bis in use
clamant que l'organisme à utiliser leur
argent pour de bonnes actions kenya et
que le reportage allait saboter ce
travail nous vous demandons d'éviter que
les communautés kényane en paie le prix
au nombre des signataires l'ancien pdg
de la halle berry le fondateur de loulou
lemon
michael pinball clemons
talk and roll the chain chez rose une
ancienne dirigeante de la banque royale
du canada
et mme heim l'ancienne première ministre
kim campbell
ce genre de journalisme ne sert aucun
intérêt public
les courriels ont afflué pendant des
jours puis dans le bade un échange de
courriel intitulé ébauche à examiner on
découvre qu'un donateur influent a
obtenu l'approbation de craig kielburger
avant d'envoyer son message à la
présidente de siby si
entre temps une source au fait de la
campagne de démentis de huy charity
avait transmis à l'équipe des documents
internes de l'organisme détaillant les
dons recueillis auprès des donateurs
fortunés les plus prisés
dans le village de ron jenna les
documents indiquent que huit donateurs
ont payé pour la même école
haïr 4,7 donateurs et fondations ont
financé les mêmes trois écoles
de plus les documents internes indiquent
qu'une école de 10000 dollars cat a
aussi été vendu à d'autres donateurs
pour 12000 dollars et même 15 mille
dollars à et cioni on voit qu'un
donateur à verser 22 mille cinq cents
dollars américains pour une seule école
il y a aussi des commentaires dans la
marge sur la façon de gérer ses généreux
philanthropes qui pourrait poser les
questions on y apprend que virgin
atlantic propriété de richard branson
n'a pas posé problème puisque personne
n'a demandé de nouvelles du projet gai
bi ghorbani une philanthrope
californienne est un cas délicat un
projet qui n'avait pas encore été
construits devra probablement être
réalisé une autre famille fortunée
paraissait plus facile à gérer puisque
ne semblait pas faire un suivi rigoureux
le donateur moyen n'a pas le bagage
nécessaire pour décortiquer
ce sera difficile à nier puisque c'est
écrit noir sur blanc
il s'agit pas juste d'une simple erreur
d'un corps qui leur a échappé
ça semble être une stratégie proactive
pour amasser beaucoup d'argent ils
misent sur le fait que les donateurs ne
pose pas de question pour pouvoir
continuer à fonctionner la sorte et ça
c'est mal et histoire
[Musique]
les frères qui augurent sont arrivées
dans cette région sauvage du kenya au
début des années 2000 ils ont convaincu
les jeunes nord-américain de recueillir
des fonds pour qu'on y construisent des
écoles des systèmes d'eau et d'autres
projets durables au fil des ans des
centaines d'écoles ont été construites
toutefois lé enquêtes de l'équipe de
siby ci a révélé que le nombre d'écoles
finances et dépasse largement le nombre
de bâtiments construit
une question s'impose donc
c'est logique de se demander où est allé
l'argent
même si l'argent a servi à financer les
programmes louable les organismes de
bienfaisance ont l'obligation éthique et
parfois légal de réaliser précisément
les programmes qu'ils se sont engagés à
faire avec l'argent des donateurs
juste avant la diffusion du reportage de
siby si oui charity envoyé une autre
lettre d'avocat
l'organisme embauchant juricomptable
pour passer en revue les fonds utilisés
dans ses projets au kenya l'organisme
insiste l'enquète journalistique sur les
fonds versés par les donateurs est
incorrect et les affirmations des
donateurs sur les médias sociaux sont
inexactes et imprécises sans toutefois
fournir de preuves
l'organisme continue de prétendre qu'on
le dit port donateurs qu'ils financent
une école lille donateurs sont informés
que leurs dons seront mis en commun pour
servir le mieux possible une région ou
un village donné
alors comment expliquer ceci
nous sommes heureux d'annoncer la salle
de classe numéro deux
était une promesse aux jeunes ou une
simple stratégie de marketing
si les donateurs ne finançait pas
entièrement les écoles pourquoi autant
de vidéos expliquent que leur argent
servira à ça
[Musique]
un run the world
des vidéos produites par wilshere et y
est par ses partenaires
[Musique]
les organismes sont habiles pour
raconter des histoires ils peuvent tous
mettre en valeur leurs bonnes actions et
les donateurs ne doivent pas se laisser
impressionner par sa barre des 1 il
s'agit de ressources publiques
ces organismes sont subventionnés par
nous tous ils ne paient pas d'impôts il
existe grâce à nous
les enquêtes sont menées quand le public
l'exigent si vous voulez savoir ce qui
est arrivé à ces écoles et à cet argent
exigé le de merde
précisément ce que rick owen exhorte les
donateurs à faire
je m'adresse aux personnes riches
influentes et bien branché aux
célébrités aux entreprises qui ont
contribué à l'ascension d'enfants
entraide et de witt cheriti
sortez de votre mutisme et exprimez-vous
comme je le fais aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous les jeunes doivent savoir qu'ils
ont droit d'exiger des réponses
de la transparence et des comptes rendus
de la part d'enfants entraide et de
witcher retail witcher
reed kaw n'a demandé 20 millions de
dollars en dommages intérêts à huit
cheriti en échange de son silence sur
l'utilisation des dons l'organisme a
qualifié sa demande d' extorsion
invoquant la co vide le scandale
politique et la diminution des dons oui
charity a annoncé en 2020 qu'elle se
retirera progressivement du canada ses
bureaux de toronto ont été vendus oui
charity entend poursuivre ses projets de
construction d'écoles au kenya
et watine jordan dans tout ça on lui a
dit qu'il avait financé une école haïr 4
cette photo de l'école numéro 4 lui a
été envoyé un souvenir de son fils
finalement j'ai été leurrés mentir aux
gens qui ont perdu un enfant à propos de
quelque chose qui est fait en leur nom
ça ne m'apparaît pas être le groupe
idéal acquis mentir
l'école numéro 4 se trouve dans le haut
d'une colline haïr 4 elle a été
entièrement financée par au moins quatre
autres donateurs la question demeure
combien d'autres personnes se sont fait
promettre la construction d'une école
qui n'a jamais vu le jour
[Musique]